oh and just saying sam blundert  i i never know what blender means  but  apparently he's in trouble now  king d6 do we like king d6 it might be  over committing those yeah  yeah i i don't think this is  c4 b6 no he's trying to get the setup  with knight and b7  javascript suggesting the the thing the  the reason machines dislike this is well  g3 g4 is quite strong followed i guess  by rook a3  onto the board and yeah the game is just  over  sam can resign now with the fairly clear  consciousness very clean rook  it's rock ending it's not exactly fun or  you can you can probably take some of  them off the board and the revelation  will not change  will probably change  well if i take a2 and f2 off the board i  think i'm still winning no no white is  winning but it's no longer plus seven  right  yeah  that's that's a very fair point yeah  [Music]  and sam did resign